welcome back everybody obviously my
little girl came to visit me on set
because the sets in our home um this
next guy though i'm about to dial in
is a real texas gentleman um you've
enjoyed him on the blue comedy tour
dancing with the stars and the
billingville show
these days you can check him out on
facebook live and in last man standing
are you there bill oh hey kell hi
my little girl literally just came in i
don't know if you were napping but she
came in for a little to say she was like
who are you talking to
this is bill this is river you know you
don't know me river but
i wait a minute wait a minute hey river
do me a favor and smile
well you know what you need to call the
police
because someone stole some of your teeth
they stole them she's just like mama i
lost my two front teeth at the same time
all right i'm gonna do this interview
all right okay i love you nice to meet
you river
her birthday is friday she's very
excited how are you kel
i'm good how are you doing well i just
want you to know that you're the only
person that i will shower in the middle
of the day for
i gotta be honest with you i don't even
know if that person exists for me
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going